por ora só é possível quebrar um copo de
vidro com voz em 321 vai o judicial de
que quem fala é o da arte sejam muito
bem vindos
também eu gosto de guiar já fica normal
janta ou e os nós vamos responder à
nossa pergunta é possível curtir um copo
de vidro com a linha dólares será que
tinha a bola só hoje vai ser um vídeo
muito interessante é porque eu vou
tentar fazer uma coisa que eu sempre vi
os filmes sempre ouvi falar que é
possível e nunca confie o que partiu um
copo de suco voz que parece funcionar o
o o
o meu vidro vibra muito mas tem que
vibrar tanto mas tanto tanto ao ponto de
partilha é isso que vou tentar fazer com
a minha voz voice system que esse tipo
assim ó mas mais ainda demais
eu não sei se vai ser possível porque
isso tem muito a ver com a genética ou
seja com minha frequência e bosko copo e
com o volume de negócio então por isso
só começou 15 estão oito gente eu
comprei vários copos rodrigues grande
ainda maior este convívio mais fino ou
não este é o vídeo mais fino tem um copo
mais pequeno e outro com o futebol é
assim mas também é então eu tenho aqui
cinco copos eu tenho certeza que você
vai encaixar com lindas de copos e
espero eu acho que consegui falar muito
porque eu vou fazer isso pediu à uma da
manhã podendo o pessoal lá em casa vai
ter de acordar com um filho com quem eu
vou conseguir porque o corpo não vou
conseguir porque num copo d'água a
expectativa era só quando ela já mudaram
já que então aproveitei desejar você
pega l'aquila e vibrou muito como assim
lycra mundo a palavra laico é por tudo
que fez por nós aqui no canal só sabem
inscreva-se com toda a força e atirou em
mim por serem todos os vídeos que mora
lá só ela é agora a festa do porco no
copo eu tenho um mix e invista lá na
rússia eu fui contar com o português
fazer é achar primeira freqüência do
vidro do cockpit que precisam disse eu
penso em fazer isso ó sozinho
esta freqüência do qual eu vou ter que
fazer um tom de voz para sair com eles
ou seja muito filme eu acho que uma
mulher consegue fazer isso mais fácil
porque ela tem a voz mais sensível e
mais firme eu acho que é mas eu vou
tentar play qual resultou o assunto mion
assim não vibra muito falar com o vidro
tendo muito como é assim chato descobrir
os segredos
eu vou precisar sair agora eu pareço uma
luta e gritava um copo como assim não
vai anular qualquer pessoa muita
concentração é preciso muita
concentração já agora só se estiver em
um copo assim deste partido em casa
peguei esse corpitcho de fazer comigo
mas claro só usem sempre óculos proteção
eu vou ter que jogar o meu falei só
vocês podem fazer isso em casa mas
sempre com os pais perto é nunca fazer
isso sozinhos por vocês podem se magoar
convido caso parta eu duvido que vocês
consigam né eu não me acho que vocês
conseguirem tenho que cuidar por aí
enock molefe xandão logo à solta um
pouco transparente para conseguir o que
eu tô eu acho que está bom então jogou
vi muito sol o taco com o the next 2 you
vamos citar shafiq concedeu um só houve
esse que é mais grave está bem filho
está mais pra você já me viu já ter
combina mais com menos
o meu deus para vibrar muito bem eu acho
que contra eu acho que isso covel como a
senhora vibrou muito eu acho que o corpo
tem que ser assustado vamos lá então o
corpo nem vai saber que o banco não
funciona só eu vou tentar encontrar
alguém que tenha feito isto unido
certamente alguém chá preto copa eu acho
que sempre vi na tv coisas assim então
vamos ver se alguém já fez isso em casa
que é uma honra jogar aqui no meu
samsung ea china não gostam têm 98 mi
light a pagar eu tenho um passo porque
eu tenho uma planeta a irmã e um canudo
assim não vai partir em poder esse grito
aí deve ser outro lado está quem não
deve ser zero ou não acredito mesmo
porque o corpo não é mito
isso funciona aí você vai mostrar amanhã
támbém contendo deve ter ficado muito
tempo a tentar né
funciona pessoal só funciona funciona
como metrô funciona 6 mil daqui
conseguiu eu também vou conseguir eu
também vou conseguir porque ela é tão
pessoal que está aqui em nossa técnica
porque eu já saí eu vi o tutorial para
lá só é possível quebrar um copo de
vidro com voz em 321 bairro
embora seja agora será não espera
preciso ter freqüência de warlley
só vou ficar aqui muito tempo a tentar
muito tempo a fazer nada ou hora difícil
é difícil acreditar que um copo e se vai
o time muito difícil do que muito tem
muito tempo o o o
o ouvir bruno muito escopo ou alhures
não fumar ainda não se lamentar não tô
sentindo algo simples mas conseguimos na
qual eu preciso uma paleta é eu preciso
qualquer coisa aqui só para sentir que
está vibra eu vou jogar aqui uma folha
por que só eu já cheguei um pouco de
papel e vamos tentar usar isso previsto
o tav brasil
assim não funciona eu estou a ficar
cansado acrescentar mais um eu não vou
sair daqui tem espanhol o desmaiar
não dá o sol quebra ficou sem bateria e
se já que também já atuou como fala por
si mesma técnica que eu vou gritar e eu
vejo livramento copa tremendo então eu
vou ter que fazer isso na perfeição só
pra ficar mais tranquilo vou tentar
fazer isso aqui só encaixar um copo mas
acho que é a primeira e nem lembrava rúa
um
vocês viram o copo mexeu mas que eu vi o
copa permitiu que mandou para o lado
sério do mês muito perto
ae estou aqui há muito tempo você não
tem um só voto e vou deixar aqui um
papel só vocês viram quase acabaram de
ver o copo vibrou muito o copo que o meu
tudo ser estava quase mesmo comentário
qualquer contato pouco mais eu acho que
o pt ocupe uma freqüência muito precisa
porque quais são os sintomas desse
experimento assim que me parece imitar
agora estou muito mais exposto
importantes vocês querem este ponto
deverá experimentar isso cop não cheguei
a esse ponto porque ela pudesse limitar
o comentador barriga
só sei que deixei muito lá e eu espero
ter muito apoio neste vídeo porque
estava a gostar imenso fazer isso mas eu
vou fazer porque eu sou assim conquistei
o cientista concerto né
o la hora para bater a falar foi
convencido a china a funcionar agora
porque não funciona
vocês não perceberam é o corpo estava na
não é parte se matam circo cinema e está
a ficar
o val eu vejo não ficar falando então
começa a ficar assim que o time muito
bom e eu acho que eu acho chato muito
proximal consegue falar estava tudo
muito chique o gol assim há muito passar
muito perto muito perto da parte de
baixo para cima aturar panatta quase 30
mil a telefã elege como assim como
estampado
andará madura barriga do computador
militar da amadora garante que isso não
vai se tomar parte em qualquer forma
acabou que bateria outra vez e bom som
eu acho que vou ficar porque o espírito
eu só não vou continuar a fazer porque
já dói muito e minha garganta e eu estou
com muita vontade de imitar a ser muito
e mesmo eu vou ficar porque com este
vídeo e eu preciso ter voz para
continuar a gravar então ele não quer
gastar a minha postura como vocês podem
ver o jato muito roubo ea menina vai
ficar pior porque quando foi descansar
amanhã cortes embora só espero que ele
não estava aqui neste vídeo eo tenha
certeza que é possível curtir um copo
com a minha voz mas eu tenho que treinar
muito então não vou responder que não
esta pergunta porque eu sei que vou
conseguir parte que já sabe só comento
em baixo se quiserem continuar a ver
este tipo de experiências mais simples
que se provou cmc mito ou não essa aqui
de parecer muito mas eu tenho certeza
que da partilha só precisa treinar ainda
mais
eu vou conseguir manter esse copo um dia
ou então vou tentar usar uma coluna
muito potente uma coluna de som com
muito mais e aguentei se vocês querem
ver isso é porque estão da acusada negou
estar a usar uma curva eu vou tentar
usar é só com os mega lá é preciso for
inscrito no canal inscrevam se carrega
no cinema por serem todos os vídeos e e
só fiquei véia próximo
o trecho